ein kaltblütiger Mord von laufender
Kamera Überwachungskameras Filmen wie
der deutsche Fabian Esser im
niederländischen Kerkrade getötet wird
das ist das holländische Fernsehen das
über diesen Fall berichtet er wird von
seinen Killern überfahren zwei Männer
die im Sekunden zuvor hunderttausend
Euro in einem Koffer abgeknöpft haben
alles gefilmt und doch sind die Täter
Weg im niederländischen TV eben hat die
Polizei diesen Fall jetzt groß
öffentlich gemacht und Bild fandet mit
diese Bilder einer Überwachungskamera im
niederländischen Kerkrade machen
sprachlos sie zeigen eine furchtbare Tat
was sich da vor laufender Kamera
abspielt ist nichts anderes als ein
kaltblütiger Mord am 23 Juni dieses
Jahres fährt der deutsche Fabian Esser
für ein vermeintliches Geschäft nach
Holland die Täter wollen angeblich ein
Haus kaufen doch in Wirklichkeit wollen
sie sein Geld Fabian hält in der Hand
einen Rollkoffer mit 100.000 Euro sein
Onkel begleitet ihn zum Treffpunkt die
Überwachungskamera filmt die beiden doch
Sekunden später zeigt dieselbe Kamera
unglaubliche Szenen ein schwarzer
Mercedes fährt vorbei der 33-Jährige
hängt an der Beifahrerseite wird
mitgeschliffen Gerät unter den Wagen und
stirbt
die Betrüger haben ihnen den Geldkoffer
entrissen laut Polizei versuchte der
deutsche Unternehmer ihre Flucht zu
verhindern
das Verfahren ist immer das gleiche die
Täter nehmen über das Internet Kontakt
mit den deutschen auf die Luxusgüter
oder Immobilien zum Kauf anbieten es ist
immer das gleiche Muster genau wie bei
Fabian und seinem Onkel
die Täter haben sich in diesem Fall als
luxemburgische Investmentgesellschaft
ausgegeben und Gebeten Bargeld zum Deal
mitzubringen
jetzt fandet die niederländische Polizei
nach den Mördern unglaublich die beiden
Täter sollen mindestens fünf ähnliche
Betrugsfälle begangen haben ihre Beute
und eine halbe Million Euro die
niederländische Polizei hat eine
Belohnung von 15.000 Euro ausgesetzt
[Musik]